(beeping)
(lively piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal.
Naked.
Large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are,
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(ambient music)
(uptempo music)
- I'm gonna present some
data from a study I did
to evaluate the ecology
of hominin scavenging
but I'll start by talking
a bit more broadly
about how archaeologists can use evidence
from butchered animal bones
to understand prehistoric meat-eating
in terms of potentially
both hunting and scavenging.
So, if someone who studies prehistory
I start with a totally blank canvas
when I attempt to reconstruct
the diets of ancient humans.
I try to paint a picture
of the past that I know
will always be incomplete.
We will never have all the pixels
but I'm dedicated to finding the filters
on the lenses through which
we can peer back in time
and try to reconstruct
something rich in detail
like this National Geographic illustration
of what I can only describe
as a hominin meat picnic.
(audience laughing)
One of the fun things about
studying hominin meat-eating
is there are so many
different lines of evidence
that we can use to do so.
We can use chimpanzee
and human forager diets
and the talks earlier today
have addressed some of these.
We can look at hominin fossils themselves,
we can look at the size
and shape of teeth.
The talk before mine by
Margaret addressed this a bit.
We can look at jaws and skulls
and we can look at even
body size and shape.
We can also look at the chemistry
which is what the talk
before mine really focused on
of those actual hominin fossils.
We can look at animal fossils
particularly those with
direct evidence for butchery
and that's what I'll focus
on a little bit after this.
To do that we often use
a method called actualism
where we either do experiments
or make observations
in the present.
We look at bones on the present for traces
left of behavior from those
experiments or observations.
We then look at fossils in the past,
see if we can find similar traces
and then we can infer
that similar behaviors
occurred in the past.
We can also look at the
archeological record
at tools made by hominins
that were used for meat-eating
and we can even use newer methods
like looking at ancient molecules.
And so less than a year half ago
a team of archeologists
announced that they found
ancient animal proteins,
basically the residue of blood,
skin and flesh from animals
on the edges of 17 stone tools
from an excavation in Jordan
dating back to 250,000 years ago.
It kind of blows my mind a bit
that now we have direct evidence
for even what kinds of animals
hominins were butchering
a quarter of a million years ago.
In this case we're talking about camels,
wild cattle, rhino, horses and duck.
So I use a method called taphonomy,
this is the lens that I
most often look through
to examine the diets of early humans.
Taphonomy is the study of
what happens to an organism
after its death until its
discovery as a fossil.
Here's a great illustration by a paper
by Nina Jablonski and
colleagues of a possible
taphonomic scenario
resulting in the accumulation
of giant panda bones in a cave in China.
I'm particularly
interested in what happens
right at and after death.
So that's that middle row really between
boxes number three and four.
And when it comes to thinking
about hominin meat-eating
the main way to investigate this
is through the study of animal
fossils with butchery marks
including cut marks made from skinning,
disarticulating and defleshing animals,
as well as percussion marks
left by bashing bones open
to get at the fat and calorie-rich marrow.
I also study tooth marks
and other chewing damage
left by carnivores.
The lens I use is literally a hand lens,
like a simple magnifying
glass that I can use
to identify these marks on fossil bones.
So I'm gonna take you
on a taphonomic timeline
of what we know about
the earliest evidence
for hominin carnivory.
And the bulk of the evidence
for the earliest carnivory
in human evolutionary history
really comes from three sites in Ethiopia.
The oldest is a 3.3 million
year old site called Dikika
where a team led by people
including Jessica Thompson
and Shannon McPherron
discovered just a handful of bones
including those pictured on the left
with possible butchery marks on them.
Two other sites from Ethiopia
called Gona and Bouri,
the bones on the right
are from pictures of bones
with butchery marks from Bouri.
Those date to 2.6 and 2.5
million years ago respectively.
They also preserve a handful
of butchery mark fossils.
While much ink has been spilled
about whether some of these marks
are actually butchery marks
and not marks made by
crocodiles, mammalian carnivores
or other butchery mark mimics
like sedimentary abrasion,
the importance of these sites
is that they signal the beginning
of a dietary shift in hominin
evolution to occasionally
but apparently only occasionally,
butchering and eating animals.
There was a shift at two million years ago
when we have the first evidence of
both persistent carnivory and
early access to small animals
and I'll explain what that means.
And the image up here is of
some butchered animal fossils
from this site called Kanjera South
in Southwestern Kenya.
This is some research
that I've been involved in
led by Rick Potts and Tom Plummer
as well as Jennifer
Parkinson and Joe Ferraro
At Kanjera there's clear evidence
from hundreds of butchery mark
fossil bones, animal bones,
that hominins acquired and processed
numerous relatively complete
small animal carcasses
for meat and marrow.
They got to these animals
first before other predators
and butchered the meatier parts of them,
so that's the early access part.
The Kanjera hominins also had at least
occasional access to meat and marrow
from larger-sized animals,
an important difference between
this and the earlier sites
where we do see evidence
of hominin butchery
is that there's evidence
for hominin butchery
on bones at Kanjera from
three stratigraphic intervals
that span hundreds to thousands of years.
So hominins were coming back
to this place in Southwestern
Kenya over and over again
over a long period of
time to butcher animals.
This is what persistent carnivory is
and this gives us a sense
that this dietary behavior
is becoming more important
or at least it's becoming
more commonplace.
Just a little bit later in time
a work led by David
Braun in a place called
Koobi Fora in Northern Kenya,
there's evidence for
hominin butchery marks on
turtles, crocodiles and fish.
So at this time hominins
are already broadening their
butchery behavior to include both aquatic
as well as terrestrial animals.
There is another shift that happened
about one and a half million years ago.
From several different bone assemblages
from the sites of Olduvai Gorge
some of which date back to
about 1.8 million years ago
and Koobi Fora some of which date back
to 1.5 million years ago
led by a variety of different teams,
there's evidence from the skeletal parts
that were transported and
butchered at these sites
hominins had early access
to large animal carcasses.
Basically they were now able
to get to these carcasses first
and butcher the meatier
parts of large animals.
The photo up here is a butchery marks
on one and a half million year
old fossil antelope leg bone
from Koobi Fora in Northern Kenya
and this is part of an
assemblage that I studied
and excavated as part of my dissertation.
So, you're probably picturing hominins
striding out onto the African savanna
armed with their stone-tipped spears
getting ready to hunt these animals.
Like this bronze sculpture
reconstruction of a Homo erectus
from the Hall of Human
Origins at the Smithsonian
carrying a goat-sized gazelle on her back.
Well the earliest solid
evidence for hunting technology
doesn't come into the record
until half a million years ago
with the spear points from
a site called Kathu Pan
in South Africa that have what are called
diagnostic impact fractures on their tips
indicating that they were definitely used
as the ends of weapons.
It's possible that hominins were hunting
with unmodified rocks or
sharpened sticks made into spears
maybe like the Fongoli chimpanzees
or other basically
archeologically invisible tools
but we haven't figured out
a way to detect this yet
in the prehistoric record.
And this is particularly likely
in the case of the small
animals at Kanjera,
so many of the small animals
themselves were juveniles
and very young defenseless antelopes
are often stashed in thick grass clumps
for several weeks by their mothers,
and doesn't take very
sophisticated technology
to basically walk up to
those little antelopes
and bop them on the head
and then you have dinner.
So what made early human carnivory
or early hominin carnivory unique
particularly compared to the possible diet
of our earliest ancestors,
as well as the diets of chimpanzees?
There are four things.
The first is that it involved big animals.
And so, animals much
larger than themselves.
As you heard from the talks earlier today,
chimpanzees don't hunt animals
that are larger than themselves.
This is a really useful reconstruction
of an extinct elephant being butchered
by a group of Homo erectus
based on a one million
year old archeological site
I'm involved in studying from
a Smithsonian research site
in Southern Kenya called Olorgesailie.
The second thing is that
it involved tool use
and rare occasions including
the Fongoli chimps aside,
we don't think that our earliest ancestors
necessarily used tools when they hunted.
Hominins also don't have the sharp teeth
of mammalian carnivores
to be able to get through
the skin of large animals,
let alone slice meat off of their bones
and bash them open to get marrow.
It also likely involves
something called deferred consumption
which is basically not
eating something right away
as soon as you find it.
This is a weird thing that humans do.
We don't go to the grocery store,
sit down in the middle the aisles,
open the packages and start eating,
I guess unless we're really hungry.
But in the earliest record
of hominin meat-eating
we have evidence that hominins
transported carcass parts
to central places for some
kind of communal consumption
potentially food sharing.
So if early humans were
eating meat from large animals
for about two million years
before we have evidence,
good solid evidence
for hunting technology,
how were they getting access to them?
One suggestion is that they
were scavenging the leftovers
from large carnivore kills
and I should point out
that this is something
that is very rarely seen
in chimpanzee behavior.
Chimps don't seem to look at dead things
and think of them as food,
things that are already dead.
So does scavenging look like
behaviorally and ecologically?
There have been two
main kinds of scavenging
that have been proposed
for early hominins.
The first is called confrontational
or aggressive or power scavenging.
This is when hominins actively
chase carnivores off of kills
presumably getting access
to a lot of meat and
marrow in the process.
There was probably a pretty
high risk of injury or predation
of the hominins themselves
when they did this.
And there are a few hominins
with bite marks on them from carnivores
to indicate that this did
happen at least occasionally.
The second is passive scavenging
and this is waiting until carnivores
are completely done eating a kill,
they've moved off, the scene is safe,
hominins could go in
and eat the leftovers.
One of the main criticisms of
the passive scavenging idea
is that there probably wouldn't
be much worth going after
when carnivores were
done eating their fill.
But is this the case?
I decided to try to answer this question
by simulating passive scavenging
in a modern African ecosystem
similar to those in which our earliest
meat-eating ancestors lived.
And I'm very happy to leave simulating
confrontational scavenging
to somebody else.
(audience laughing)
So is passive scavenging worth it?
The research I'll be talking about here
was part of my dissertation
and it was published a few years ago
in the Journal of Human Evolution.
In 2002 to 2003, I spent
seven months in a game reserve
in central Kenya called
Ol Pejeta Conservancy
which you can see here on
a zoomed in map of Kenya,
and I simulated passive scavenging.
I specifically chose this
conservancy, Ol Pejeta,
because the felid, the
the carnivore community
is dominated by lions
and most models of hominin scavenging
are based on interactions
with large felids
including lions, leopards
and extinct saber tooths.
There have been a few
other scavenging studies
that were done before mine
but these were done in the Serengeti
and Ngorongoro ecosystems of Tanzania,
as well as the Maasai
Mara ecosystem of Kenya
that's actually all one big ecosystem
that happens to be separated
by an international border.
But these ecosystems have unusually
high numbers of predators
and particularly high competition
among predator species.
So I was interested in going
to a felid-dominated ecosystem
to simulate passive scavenging.
Ol Pejeta is an African savanna ecosystem,
it was about a hundred square
kilometers when I was there.
It was called Sweetwaters
Game Reserve when I was there.
Now it's been expanded to
almost four times that size.
And here you see some images
of what it looked like there.
It has mixed grassland
and woodland vegetation,
all the photos on this slide are photos
I took in the reserve.
The vegetation map on the top left
shows open grassy areas that are in black.
They generally run east to
west on kind of high plateaus.
The photos with the giraffe
with the zebras in the background
are a good example of what those
open grassy areas look like.
There's a permanent river
called the Ewaso Ng'iro
that runs north south through the reserve.
You can see that on the western side
with that green strip.
That green is basically
riverine vegetation,
trees particularly dominated
by yellow fever acacia
or acacia that's xanthophloea.
There's a picture of
that on the top right.
The dominant bush in the
ecosystem is called euclea.
This is noted in the bright blue areas,
you can see that on the top middle.
Whistling thorn acacia
or acacia drepanolobium
are also very prevalent,
those are noted in light
blue on the vegetation map.
And the yellow and pink areas on that map
are areas of mixed bushland,
woodland and grassland
in kind of different proportions.
The predator community
during the time of my study
was dominated by lions
as I mentioned already
and the herbivore community
was dominated by zebras
followed by warthog,
impala, buffalo and baboon.
So, my study methods were pretty simple.
After finding out about a carnivore kill
from a variety of sources
I would wait until the lions
were completely satiated
like this one in this photo
with a distended belly full of warthog,
this was a really happy sleepy lion,
and I would document what
was left on their kills.
I had two advantages over
my earlier ancestors.
I had a four-wheel drive vehicle
and I had an armed guard
with me at all times
lessening the likelihood of me becoming
one of my own samples.
(audience laughing)
In the time that I was at Ol Pejeta
I collected 24 kill samples
from several different
species of carnivores
which you can see in the
left column of this table
but I'm gonna focus particularly
on the lion kills today
as that's my largest sample
and the most relevant for thinking about
models of hominins scavenging.
I separated the prey
into two size divisions
related to how we classify
the size of animals
when we're doing archeological analysis,
but here I'm just generally
calling them large or small.
Larger animals are over 250 pounds,
small animals less than 250 pounds.
I documented the location and estimated
the amount of meat left over
after the lions had their fill
and here are some examples
of what these leftovers looked like.
The top right is a
picture of a zebra ribcage
with quite a bit of meat left on it
and the bottom right is a
picture of a part of a limb
of a young Grant's gazelle
with hardly any scraps left.
And I should say specifically
that I followed previous
researchers in defining
bulk flesh as masses of muscle more
at least 10% of their original size,
flesh scraps were usually pieces of flesh
less than size of the palm of your hand
but over two to three centimeters
and weighing more than
about a third of a pound.
So how much meat can a scavenger eat
from a large animal,
something like a zebra
or a large antelope?
I'm gonna walk you through
the axis of this graph
before I show you the data.
So the x-axis is a
skeletal element or bone
arranged in groups from left to right
with the total sample size of each bone
listed in parentheses.
The important part is the left two bones,
they're bones of the hindlimb,
then bones of the forelimb,
then bones of the torso
and all the way on the right
are bones of the head and neck.
The y-axis is the
proportion of those bones
in all samples with three different levels
of flesh availability,
and I basically colored
them like a traffic light.
Green for bulk flesh,
yellow for flesh scraps
and red for no flesh.
So what did I find?
You see a lot of green
and yellow on there.
In large kills over 50%
of bones were abandoned
with large muscle masses
still on them in green
and 95% of the bones had either bulk flesh
or flesh scraps which you see in yellow.
That's from large prey.
Small prey is a different story.
Only a single bone on smaller lion kills
retained bulk flesh on it.
About half the bone still
had some flesh scraps
and the other half were totally defleshed,
you can see that in red.
And one take-home from the study
is that if you're an early human
scavenging from a lion kill,
the size of the prey really matters.
So, how does this translate into actually
how much meat a scavenger could eat?
We can use weights of
adult wildebeest and zebra
which are pictured here.
The hindlimb of wildebeest
yields about 19 pounds of meat,
a zebra about 50 pounds.
A defleshed hindlimb of a wildebeest
would be about two pounds,
defleshed zebra about five pounds.
That's only a single hindlimb.
A defleshed wildebeest carcass
could yield 12 pounds of meat.
A defleshed a zebra
carcass could yield about
34 pounds of meat.
So if we estimate a four
calories per gram of meat
this is about 2,200
calories from a wildebeest
and almost 6,100 calories from a zebra
and these are defleshed.
So, translating this into
things we can understand here
that's about a little
more than five and a half
In-N-Out burgers worth of
meat from a wildebeest,
a little more than 15 and a half in
burgers worth of meat from a zebra.
I'm using an estimate of somewhere between
2,100 and 2,300 calories per day
required for Homo erectus.
A defleshed wildebeest is pretty much
your daily caloric requirement.
This is even without breaking the bones
to get at the marrow inside.
So the main take-home message
is that I think scavenging
from even relatively defleshed carcasses
would have been a profitable
and worthwhile activity for hominins.
I just want to acknowledge
Government of Kenya,
the funding, my PhD advisor
and the people and the predators
and the prey of Ol Pejeta.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(uptempo music)